then welcome to this video bit of a late
start here my let's play the DeCaro
again I got a request for the 97 line
the cup of variational Smith's love
variation but now probably a pizza pan
off we're always played this knight c6
variation this is what I had recommended
and the size you see serious this funny
nighty fault line has netted me many
wins already people simply have no idea
what to do some quite quite cool at
times okay it's probably simply this
because some now I'm winning a tempo on
the bishop and here's some quite
strangest time usage okay but he's got
10,000 games or something okay yeah
those long things on simply captures are
always a bit weird but is probably just
not the quickest player okay um yeah
Knight f3 looks very normal but um
Bishop to g4 is something you need to
take into account this bishop on g5s
somewhat expose exposed maybe am white
should consider to play a move like you
should be three dropping it back
deliberately yeah he's taking really
much time even he's even slower than
than me which is quite something
hmm Wow
quite irritating Bishop to our form yeah
probably probably this is the most
aggressive way to play this and now we
need form mmm okay Bishop to c5 now yeah
looks like looks good intending to take
and I've got Queenie five also yeah this
already seems quite interesting for
black
yep let's take this
yeah just III m our does he protects III
and e5 probably he will play Knight f3
em okay this is this may be easier just
play this on the tech c3 and III Queen
d2 with some probably the move
to protect both pawns you know Knight f3
to defaults the the defense of IDM like
to prevent it if possible but don't
really see how hmmm else it annoying
that I cannot prevent it took care of
course you can just
just play simple moves and increase the
pressure on the upon
well yeah this is the simplest if he
goes 94 95 not improving is pawn
structure allowing a capture on c6 I
just go rupee aid and let's say Bishop
f5 to you for something like this is a
good way to to play hmm but even sure
how he defends us now a possible counter
players on f7 we should both Bishop c4
yeah exactly
hmm
should I take anyway ya bish would be
success of course another principal
dancer but he could take and plain ig5
take Queenie 695 which I don't really
don't really lie
yeah it's it's okay for black but it's
not um it's not super convincing
hmm
yeah okay let's let's do this so okay
and I was really thinking take center 95
but take take Bishop e8 hmm
hmm yeah okay
yeah this weird move
yeah I probably miss played that this
seems really unnecessary this kind of
weird complications
but it seems he's very consistent with
his plan of losing on time before move
21 and now it's moving okay I can take
now him
yeah 26 the Sun running into 97 I can
take with the palm down leaving me with
the better the better minor piece so
really good piece on d5 yeah I'm not
quite sure what he was doing with this
time management um yeah I somehow I fear
to to win in the opening straight maybe
okay I can't take g2 but this looks very
nice but somehow somehow he wriggled out
of this rock da diem then we must be ll
computer always gives me gives me some
advantage but it's not like a total
reputation which really is what you what
you need to do after after all this yeah
computer let's take him on g2 so didn't
think about that at all but yeah its
fifth it's quite it's quite good I mean
this is Swiss cheese snow white's
remaining pawns yeah this is much better
simply because his King never will find
any sort of protection mmm alright
thanks for watching this game